i i do some investing in the health and
fitness sector as well and i've seen the
valuation of some of these like home
fitness companies you know the peloton s
companies like
tonal and mirror and catalyst
and fight club um and
of course peloton as well just explode
and obviously you need to be connected
to use those type of products during
your session some of them allow for like
offline downloading of the workouts
which i actually encourage people to do
if they can
because it's one less distraction one
less notification going off on your
device while you're working out
etc and possibly you know even a bigger
thing here that a lot of people don't
think about is
all of these devices you know all these
things you need to be connected to
they do emit low level radiation
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
human performance consultant
a speaker and a new york times
best-selling author of
17 yeah 17 books including beyond
training boundless and fit soul
ben greenfield welcome to the reuben
report hey what's going on man
ben this is the first time for me i have
never had a guest i've probably
interviewed about a thousand people at
this point i don't think i've ever had a
guest
uh just sort of wandering in the forest
first time really have you ever had a
guest wandering in the forest naked
are you bare ass naked well you know in
this area you never know when somebody's
wearing pants but
yeah considering that i'm walking
through the neighborhood and not
strolling on the treadmill in my office
i did have to pull on a little bit of
clothing
but uh i'll i'll try not to uh to have
any wardrobe malfunctions during our
during our show here fair enough i just
like to like to get my vitamin d you
know
yeah yeah this is youtube not pornhub
let's keep it clean um all right so as
you know
right now i am off the grid completely
we are taping this at the end of july
for an august release release i am
completely
away from cell phones all tech
television news the whole thing i'm
working on diet
i'm working on exercise and i'm working
on a digital detox
uh let's start there with the digital
detox situation as a guy that's doing uh
youtube interviews while doing exercise
and wandering around
i take it uh you think maybe we're a
little too connected these days
well first of all i don't know how the
heck you're staying fit
during a digital detox without being
able to be motivated by all the
instagram influencers out there
because we all know the best way to get
fit is via osmosis and scrolling through
uh
through babe and hulk feeds on instagram
but right
that being said yeah i um you know i i
i i honestly like you know i
i really took a great deal of pride for
years and be like one of those
hyper-connected guys
and by hyper-connected i don't mean on
social media all day but i mean
you know using all the wearables the
self-quantification devices the super
computers on my bike the power meters on
my
laces for running you know the the
swimming goggles that tell you how many
laps you swum you know with like a
screen right there in the goggles
and um and
you know i i really like to be a little
bit more unplugged now i'm pretty bare
bones when it comes to fitness i wear
like a ring that tracks
my step count my sleep and a cheap ass
15
timex you know and that's that's about
all that i do
now but you know i think even more
related to your point
is this idea that you know the
the more connected you are
the more difficult it can be to to move
and to exercise because you know it's
just difficult to engage on something
like social media
while you're working out you know which
is obviously why half the people at a
gym have their asses parked on a bench
hunched over looking on their phones
rather than you know
before that it was all it was magazines
on the tv you know now it's just
replaced by by phones but you know i um
i think that that there there can be
some efficacy to this stuff like i've
even seen during kovid
i mean some of these companies because i
do some investing in the health and
fitness sector as well
and i've seen the valuation of some of
these like home fitness companies you
know the peloton s
companies like tonal and mirror
and catalyst and fight club
um and of course peloton as well just
explode
and obviously you need to be connected
to use those type of products
during your session some of them allow
for like offline downloading of the
workouts which i actually encourage
people to do if they can
because it's one less distraction one
less notification going off on your
device while you're working out
etc and possibly you know even a bigger
thing here that a lot of people don't
think about is
all of these devices you know all these
things you need to be connected to
they do emit low-level radiation that
could be problematic
in terms of your mitochondrial function
your red blood cell what's called red
blood cell stickiness or the
propensity of red blood cells to
aggregate together the uh
the calcium influx into a cell which
causes a little bit more of a burn
and a slower ability to be able to
buffer lactic acid and some of the
things that build up during lactic acid
or during
exercise a lot of that stuff actually
becomes affected by exposure to
um you know uh your your cell phone
signal
5g wi-fi etc that's why a lot of people
during a day of work you only get brain
fog they feel kind of blah
in the afternoon they don't sleep well
they got a bunch of devices next to
their bed
and so i question you know the impact
some of those things are having on you
while you're exercising as well if you
are using those type of things
during exercise then of course the use
apart from exercise is just
it can be a time suck but there's you
know there's some efficacy i'm not
i i see a ton of benefit in social media
for spreading a lot of good knowledge
and information
obviously it can spread disinformation
negativity as well but
you know i think when responsibly used
it's a big blessing yeah you mentioned
uh
tonal and mirror and i just was at the
mall the other day i saw a tonal so it's
basically like these
mirror type i mean they're literally
mirrors that you stand in front of to
work out
they have some uh you know some things
you can pull on and
yeah you know they're connected to the
internet and all that do you think uh
there's a risk in
people actually doing this stuff all
from home and not going to the gym not
being around other people getting that
kind of motivation
uh well first um
not not really because they they enable
people to
be able to actually just lower the
barrier of entry right if you can roll
out of bed and walk over
to your whatever your basement or your
your backyard or whatever and just
use a home training device and
furthermore relate to the safety
component
use a home training device that now has
the ability to have a personal trainer
you know or an expert walking you
through the workout and again sometimes
like
you know i do like full body electrical
muscle stimulation workouts which sounds
crazy but it's very simple you just pull
on this suit and it stimulates your
muscles while you're exercising so you
use more muscles
um it has a personal trainer that walks
you through the workout but i can
download all those workouts because
they're pre-recorded
and um it's it's actually
very very similar to what you might
experience in a group fitness class at a
health club or or a gym so i'm not
really against that i mean i
i think that probably the two main
things that we miss out on
by not being able to go to a health club
or gym
or by kind of kind of like making those
highly optional due to the emergence of
a lot of these
higher-end home fitness training devices
is that a
we know that human beings thrive
on connectivity to other human beings
touch
eyes even the electromagnetic signals
sent out by our hearts
and our brains we are designed to be
social creatures just based on
you know that that whole idea that you
know in
more ancestral times to be banished or
cut off from the village or from your
tribe
usually resulted in death and we still
have kind of that
that nervous system and physiological
response to isolation
that causes a lot of the health issues
that we're now seeing we saw before
covid we see it more now
just this idea that human beings don't
thrive
when we are alone for long periods of
time
and digital interactions do not replace
the
the what happens physiologically during
physical interactions
uh and then the in addition to missing
out on that
and you know that can be replaced by
dinner partings and outings and
hanging out with friends etc but the
other thing is that
there's a lot of value as well to shared
experiences
right and and honestly um that's even
more important for men than for women
you know men tend to bond over shared
experiences shared workouts
shared you know noon basketball games at
the gym shared tennis matches like
that's how guys a lot of times form
friendships that's one thing i found
is you know when i want to make friends
i'll invite him out for frisbee golf or
you know to over to my house to do a do
a garage workout or something like that
and
you know if you're always working out by
yourself in front of some mirror mirror
on the wall
you know at your house you're also
missing out on that so i would say
if you're aware of the importance of
real human interaction and shared
experiences and you're fabricating those
somewhere else in your life
then you know working out by yourself at
home with some of these home fitness
training devices especially because of
like i mentioned the low barrier to
entry that occurs when you don't have to
get in the car
drive to the gym you know figure out
what time the class is show up
shower go home you know for me
personally
if i have a chance to work out during
the day it's like a 20 or 30 minute slot
a couple times during the day
and i could use all that time driving to
the gym or i could just hop out to my
garage
or my backyard or my basement throw
something down that's what i do like
90 of the time and i get all my social
interaction through you know
group dinners and and uh you know and
church outings and you know playing
tennis with folks and stuff like that so
see i i still think the pros outweigh
the cons of a lot of these these trendy
fitness devices for home
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
lifestyles instead of non-stop yelling
check out our lifestyle playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe
and click the notification bell